Jetzt ist es absolut sicher es gibt wasser eis auf dem mond neue auswertungen bestätigen
direkt funde am nord- und südpol die absorption von infrarotlicht zeigt dass es an den polen
unmengen von wassereis gibt wie es gefunden wurde und was das für die mondmissionen in zukunft bedeutet klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen und am ende des videos gibt es noch eine kleine sensation wir krempeln nämlich youtube um die
Entdeckung von wasser auf dem mond ist eine lange geschichte denn selbst nachdem die apollo-missionen gestein von dort mitgebracht hatten
vermutete niemand wasser auf dem mond oder gar sogar in diesen proben doch weit gefehlt
2010 wurde das mondgestein nach jahrzehnten nochmals untersucht und tatsächlich wurde wasser darin entdeckt unter dem mikroskop
wurden winzige anschlüsse in vulkanischen glas und darin in gesteins bildenden uni wien
kristallen gefunden und schon 2009 entdeckte der
manager der nasa an bord der indischen sonde chandrayaan-1 wasser auf dem mond
600 millionen tonnen sollen es dort in tiefen kratzern am nordpol geben demnach dort auf dem grund wo kein
sonnenlicht hinkommt soll es als eis existieren und im juli 2017
wurden daten der sonde präsentiert die sogar wasser im gesamten mond mattl nachwiesen und zwar in einer ähnlichen
konzentration wie im erdmantel auch hier auf der erde soll sich noch im erdmantel der von rund 70 kilometern
tiefe unter der erdoberfläche bis zu rund
2900 kilometern tiefe reicht wasser in der menge der ganzen
ozeane befinden ähnliche mengen werden dann auch auf dem mond im verhältnis zu seiner größe zu finden sein nur wäre es kaum zu gewinnen
doch ein weiteres experiment förderte im wahrsten sinne des wortes
wassereis zutage die nasa ließ im oktober 2009 den l cross satelliten auf den mond stürzen
er wirbelte 5 tonnen staub auf und darin befanden sich sechs prozent gefrorenes wasser
eine nicht unbeachtliche menge der mond ist also da ja richtig feucht aber einigermaßen feucht und die ice vorkommen an nord und südpol
denn die neueren untersuchungen
jetzt auch ähnliche vorkommen am südpol bestätigt sind dabei am spannendsten und können am
leichtesten für mond missionen genutzt werden deshalb wurden diese vorkommen jetzt noch mal analysiert und für beide regionen bestätigt die
absorption von infrarotlicht der moleküle am krad an grund entspricht genau der signatur von wasser
damit ist es jetzt wirklich sicher es gibt auf dem mond wasser und zwar in
erheblichen mengen das auch in solchen mengen vorhanden ist dass es für zukünftige mondmissionen
genutzt werden damit würden mondmissionen viel einfacher werden statt wasser mit dorthin zu nehmen könnte es dort gewonnen werden der effekt
geplanten missionen werden viel billiger weil weniger wasser und damit auch weniger treibstoff benötigt wird ein
riesenschritt für die planung künftiger missionen
die esa die europäische raumfahrtagentur hat ja bereits mit den planungen begonnen und diese erkenntnisse werden diese planung erheblich
vereinfacht und auch die amerikaner wollen wieder zum mond genauso wie die russen und die chinesen
der wettlauf hat also wieder begonnen so und jetzt kommt es wir machen clixoom
werbefrei keine rolle mehr und ihr könnt das na ja fast
unmögliche möglich machen denn ohne euch geht es nicht immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben
schalten wir die werbung von jeweils einem video im monat ab bis es vor
keinem video mehr werbung gibt werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien
einfach hier unter dem video auf mitglied werden klicken tausend dank an all diejenigen die schon dabei sind und das möglich machen werden
werbefreies klingt so
das wäre doch wirklich mal der hammer wenn er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die bei einigen etwas unzuverlässige am boxi auf youtube und er verpasst kein video einfach hier draufklicken
und hier da unten geht es weiter mit dafür auch dortigen menschen sollen auf dem mond siedeln bis dann
bleibt dran